Film Courage: Keith I’m hearing the word
product come up a lot and I love it.
I love that you are thinking of a film as
a product.
It’s not just a project, it’s not just
something you’ve created (a work of art,
whatever) where are you getting this?
Because I’m thinking of a product sometimes
as a piece of code someone has written, they’ve
turned it into an app (whatever).
But you’re seeing a film as a product?
Keith Sutliff, filmmaker: Right, Well, essentially
a film it’s a piece of art, it is.
It’s a piece of art that is also a product
in the sense that this is a business.
And more people, you make a short film.
Usually short films don’t make money, the
don’t get distribution, they are not really
meant for that, so that is not really something
you sell.
But when you get into the feature film world
it’s like going from college football to
the NFL, you’re going up the ladder where
it’s so time-consuming and it’s so much
money involved that once you step up that
ladder and step up to the plate you’re kind
of telling the industry like “Hey, I’m
ready to…I like making films, I passionate
about this or whatever.
I’m also here to sell films, too.”
Because making a feature, they’re a piece
of art but also it’s a product in the sense
of this is all a business.
You’re there to sell as well as make the
film so that’s something (the way I see
it) it’s a business overall.
That’s really what it comes down to.
And if you’re passionate about it and that’s
something you enjoy doing, and it’s a piece
of art and it’s something that I see that’s
also I want to sell it too and have people
see it (not just make it for a two-year period
or however long it takes).
Film Courage: Has anyone ever challenged you
over that?
“Oh, man.
You keep calling your film a product.
Can you just call it a film?”
Keith: Not really.
I just think that it’s, like I said if you
just want to go make a piece of art and just
see it only as just that, then go ahead and
make it (your short films) because that’s
less time-consuming.
But once you’re making a feature, that’s
like a totally different animal.
You’re spending every waking moment of your
life on that thing it seems like (at least
for me that’s how it was).
Every waking moment of your life, energy,
sacrificing friendships (I mean time with
friends and family).
And yeah, you stepped up to that plate to
where you’re passionate about this but also
you want to start selling your films and make
it a business that’s really what it comes
down to when you start making features.
So when you’re in that level and that category
you stepped up to “Hey, I’m a feature
film director.
You are also a businessman, that’s essentially
what you are.
If you’re doing short films and you’re
just trying to do that for fun, you can try
to sell those, too (yes).
But feature films are really what distributors
buy into and they’ll start selling and stuff.
So at that point you are there to sell something
that you’re passionate about and it’s
also a piece of art, but it’s the product
in that sense.
Film Courage: So calling it a product (it
sounds like in your mind) doesn’t diminish
the fact that it’s creative and you put
your ideas and these different fantasies in
your head whatever but it also means that
there is money on the line and there is accountability
with it.
Keith: Correct.
And I equate it almost to let’s say an engineer
makes something.
It takes him two years or three years to make
it.
Almost sure as an engineer or whatever he
is doing in that field like he’s passionate
about what he likes to do.
He might even see it as some type of art of
whatever (something that he loves to do, right)?
But also he is there to make this thing and
he’s there to sell it, too at that point.
So I kind of see it as that.
Like engineers taking this product, taking
this piece of work, building it up and then
they are putting it out in the market.
So that’s kind of the way I see it in a
certain sense as well.
But you’re passionate about it as well and
it is a piece of art that is also this.
But it’s also this on top of that (a product
that is something to sell).
Film Courage: Right, like an inventor from
years past.
Keith: Yeah, it’s an invention technically.
It’s like making anything technically and
then selling it.
Taking years to make it but you’re passionate
about it obviously because you wouldn’t
take years making it because you wouldn’t
spend years making something unless you really
enjoyed it.